[Music]
on this Sunday night the struggle to
survive inside a Gaza Hospital the life
and death battle for newborns as
incubators lay idle so sh hospital now
is out of service this is the situation
the escalating humanitarian crisis as
Medics fight to save patients without
power now demonstrations in 40 locations
across Canada calling for a ceasefire
the non-stop bombing a 4our ceas fire
it's ridiculous and a Montreal Jewish
school is hit by gunshots again Canadian
fashion Mogul Peter nyard guilty of
sexual assault this is a battle one in a
much bigger War what his son says
happened when he spoke out against his
dad and how dust from 66 million years
ago changed Life as We Know
It global National with bar Asser good
evening 234 Canadian citizens residents
and their families left Gaza today
through the Rafa border crossing that's
according to Global Affairs Canada and
it's in addition to the 107 people who
crossed into Egypt last week inside The
Enclave healthc care is crumbling the
World Health Organization says gaza's
largest hospital is not a functioning
Hospital anymore the head of the who
says the world cannot stand silent while
hospitals which should be safe havens
are transformed into scenes of death
Devastation and despair and we want to
warn you again tonight that some of the
images you're about to see in our
coverage will be difficult to
watch according to the wh the alifa
hospital has faced 3 days without
electricity power with constant gunfire
and bombings in the area the Israeli
military says it has opened a corridor
for anyone who wants to leave but the
aid group Doctors Without Borders says
its staff has has witnessed people being
shot at outside and that it's too
dangerous to go outside to help them as
Danielle hamam Jan reports what is clear
is the sickest in Gaza are not getting
the medical help they need not even the
youngest patients some of these babies
likely all of them are younger than the
war itself there is now not enough
electricity left to power the generators
it means having to take the newborns off
their
incubators doctors at alifa hospital say
the women's Ward was bombed and so here
they are sleeping next to each other on
a single bed at least three have died
staff say they expect to lose more day
after day we nearly sure that we are
alone now no one hear us but we want
someone to give us the guarantee that
they can Evacuate the patient satellite
images show the destruction of hospitals
in The
Enclave shifa is is the largest of them
all Doctors Without Borders says Medics
and patients are trapped
[Music]
inside due to heavy clashes around the
hospital complex even if you are wounded
or injured in the Gaza area you cannot
be evacuated by ambulance to sha
hospital so shfa hospital now is out of
service this is the
situation but the Israeli military
offered a different account claiming it
supplied 300 L of fuel for urgent
medical purposes here's a video it says
shows Israeli troops placing Jerry cans
near the hospital as had been
coordinated in advance with officials at
Al shifa Israel says Hamas then
prevented the medical center from
receiving
them it has also repeatedly claimed that
hamas's headquarters are located under
the hospital the focus of the is Israeli
military campaign one bolstered by
weapons supplied by its daous Ally but
the US is warning Israel we do not want
to see a firefight in a hospital where
innocent people helpless people uh
people seeking Medical Care are caught
in the
crossfire the alud hospital also
announced it was out of
service and still in Northern Gaza and
in the dark surgeries at the Indonesian
Hospital Hospital are being carried out
in
corridors that's M's little body on the
floor doctors tried to save his life
using a manual
resuscitator and they
succeeded over the past few days more
than a 100,000 residents have been
forced to flee South not knowing if or
when they'll ever return parents do not
know what to tell their children
the anger is not only directed at
Israel this is not a way to live the
Arab world has let us down he says why
don't they come and help rid us of the
occupation that is bombing us left and
right the whole world has let us down he
says the progressive world that boasts
about human rights has let us down over
the weekend Israel said its forces would
take the babies from Al shifa hospital
to safety but now claim they've not been
told how to get them out there are at
least 40 newborn babies off incubators
and Farah the clock is ticking certainly
is Danielle Hamin in Jerusalem tonight
thank you Danielle as Israel aay Siege
on Gaza there are more signs the
situation is escalating Beyond
it on the border between Israel and
Lebanon Israeli forces exchanged gun
fire and bombardments with Hezbollah
Fighters This after the iran-backed
militant group fired missiles upon
Israeli border Villages more than a
dozen people were injured including
Israeli troops it's the latest Skirmish
after weeks of fighting in the region
triggered by the
crisis and in Europe the conflict is
further opening bitter divisions across
France tens of thousands of people
marched against anti-Semitism following
a arise in hate incidents and in the UK
there is more political Fallout after
police arrested far right prot Chesters
is looking to interrupt a pro
Palestinian March this weekend in both
countries many citizens are closely
watching the words and the actions of
their politicians on this very
contentious issue Redmond Shannon
reports French politicians of different
Stripes belt out the national anthem La
mares at the start of a March against
anti-Semitism among them the leader of
the far-right national rally party party
Marine
Leen we are exactly where we should be
she said leen's father and Party founder
Jean Marie Leen was repeatedly accused
of anti-Semitic views during his career
at the other end of the political
Spectrum however Jean Luke melanon did
not attend the left-wing leaders said
the event was for quote unconditional
supporters of the massacre of gazin the
decisions of both politicians reflecting
deepening divisions on the Middle East
across much of
Europe in London King Charles later
wreath at the city's main Senate half
for the traditional remembrance Sunday
event it was the sight of these clashes
between far-right protesters and police
during Saturday's
commemorations the group tried to storm
the Senate half supposedly to protect it
others attempted to intercept London's
Pro Palestinian March before being
arrested opposition politicians accuse
the Home Secretary Suella Braverman of
inciting the clashes her Ministry is in
charge of policing but on Wednesday she
accused officers of bias toward Pro
Palestinian protests and braan used
similar language to Ontario Premier Doug
Ford labeling them hate marches we have
a Home Secretary whose job it should be
to ensure that tensions are simmered
down has spent the entire week Fanning
the Flames of division London Police did
also arrest some Pro Palestinian
protesters in relation to hate crime
offenses but regardless of what
political leaders say and do it should
be worth noting one thing the vast
majority of those taking to the streets
on both sides of the English Channel
this weekend did so peacefully Redman
Shannon news
London dozens of demonstrations were
held across Canada today calling for
peace in the region the group called
ceasefire now planned the day of action
with more than 40 Pro Palestinian
rallies planned in various parts of the
country today the most important point
for today is to call for ceasefire to
call on our officials to have the
courage to call for a ceasefire I'm here
to fight for for the rights of the
Palestinian people to live uh their
right to be free their right to have
their own
land islamophobia and anti-Semitism are
both on the rise across Canada as our
hate crimes a Jewish school in Montreal
is dealing with a second incident within
just a few days Mckenzie gray
reports for the second time in less than
a week a Brazen display of anti-Semitism
in Montreal an early morning shooting at
a Jewish school that had been targeted
just days before they want to try and
scare us into closing our schools into
not educating our children they will
fail our school has been here for 75
years Montreal police say they were
called at 5:00 a.m. to the Yeshiva
gadola Jewish school bullet holes
riddled the facade but no one was inside
or injured Witnesses told police they
saw a vehicle speeding off after the
shots were fired this what happened
today it's not Montreal we don't want
people in Montreal we don't want
montrealers to feel unsafe in their City
this is absolutely unacceptable no
arrests have been made but police are
now investigating it as a hate crime
just like the probe into a Molotov
cocktail being thrown at a Southwestern
Montreal synagogue on November 7th we
will of course have more security but
also I'm definitely telling them that uh
the what the perpetrator of of what
happened will be there will be
consequences tensions are also high in
the nation's capital no one was hurt
when gasoline was ped in a clinical area
of the Ottawa General Hospital on
Thursday accompanied by a message
discussing the ongoing conflict in Gaza
according to police and an Ottawa mosque
had feces smeared on it in late October
the video caught on CCTV what's been
happening uh you know particularly what
we saw in Montreal last week on the west
block with Mercedes Stevenson the
government house leader calling for calm
I think really importantly to create
that space for dialogue to make sure
that we continue to see and view each
other as fellow Canadians conservative
leader Pier POV labeling the unknown
perpetrators of the shooting as
terrorists our school Yesa Montreal has
been the target of a terrorist attack I
say again a terrorist attack that
sentiment is supported by some backbench
liberal MPS but so far no word on what
the Prime Minister thinks Farah as
Justin Trudeau has not made a public
statement on the
shooting McKenzie gray in Ottawa thank
you
McKenzie jurors have found former
Canadian fashion Mogul Peter nyard
guilty of four counts of sexual assault
he was acquitted on a fifth count and a
charge of forcable confinement Mike trle
with the jury verdict reached this
morning in
Toronto guilty get guilty Shannon [__]
broke the news to Peter nygard's victims
women she had worked with as a trauma
therapist their story is now validated
by guilty verdicts on four counts of
sexual assault he was acquitted on one
count of sexual assault and one of
forceable confinement it's relief it's
victory it's Joy it's pain it's
disappointment nyard the 82-year-old
former fashion Mogul was a self-made
millionaire who lived a jet set
lifestyle surrounded by models and
celebrities also in court today his son
Kai who says he was silenced by lawyers
and disinherited by his father in 2019
when he tried to come forward as a
whistleblower he says he felt Vindicated
when civil suits were launched 6 months
later against a man he now calls a
monster I loved my father it hurts me to
see all of these things I knew a
different man but when you get the
reveal that there is another person
there's another personality within there
there's something evil in there there's
something perverse there's something
sick over the past 6 weeks the jury
heard from five women who testified they
visited nigar's Toronto office under the
pretense of a tour or job interview each
recalled being invited to nigar's top
floor bedroom Suite where they testified
they were sexually assaulted when
niggard took the stand he said he didn't
recall ever meeting four of the five
women in closing arguments the crown
said similarities in their testimony
defy coincidence while the defense
called their stories revisionist history
and totally Preposterous suggesting most
of the complainants were part of a class
action lawsuit filed against nyard in
the US complicating matters the alleged
assaults happened from the 1980s to the
mid 2000s leading to some witness
inaccuracies in Remembering details and
while the crown argued that was to be
expected defense lawyer Brian Greenspan
argued it wasn't merely flawed
recollection it was Alice in Wonderland
Greenspan says it's too early to say if
they'll launch an appeal his Focus right
now is to get a favorable jail sentence
uh as you've all seen Mr niggard is H is
frail has uh numerous health challenges
and that will be part of the position
taken nigar's legal Journey doesn't end
here he's facing more charges in
separate cases in Quebec and Manitoba
and once those trials are complete he'll
be extradited to the US for yet another
trial Mike drle Global News
Toronto serving for Canada and being
served an eviction notice coming up the
plight of a homeless veteran this
Remembrance Day
weekend a Canadian Soldier who's done
two tours in Afghanistan is homeless
this Remembrance Day weekend his home
seized just as winter sets in Melissa
Rin
explains here is where Sergeant Zack
mcdermit F's H stood this would have
been the this would have been the front
door right here if the house was still
uh still here this kind of where our
front door came out a decade old fight
over building permits and what the
municipality calls safety concerns at
the family of six's mobile home when
they first said that they would remove
the house and tear our garage down that
we've been living here for 9 and 1 half
years um it's not that I didn't take it
seriously cuz I definitely took it
seriously I just thought that it would
never get to that point because I mean
even even if you can do something
doesn't mean that you
should by house but they did on October
30th Nicole mcdermit foutz was home with
their two youngest when police movers
and a flatbed truck arrived with a
warrant to seize the home I was actually
nursing the B
baby nursing the baby and uh Zach phoned
me with the heads up and I guess they
were already at the gate and by the time
I got off the phone with him they were
at the front door all she could do is
watch from her
car shut up she and the kids are staying
with family and come to visit their dad
living here in the garage the rural
Municipality of whad would not do an
interview but sent Global News a
statement from their lawyer saying the
property owners were provided
appropriate notice and all procedures
were followed in accordance with the
municipal act and bylaws to remove the
unpermitted structure it's the talk of
this rural community total shock can't
believe that a house would be taken away
from a family like overreach I call it
Bernice Hebert started a GoFundMe for
the
family in addition to losing their home
mcdermit foutz and his wife each face a
$40,000 fine the RM is billing them for
the mover's storage container and their
legal bill bills it's heartbreaking to
see people in different countries who
are really live under tyranny and then
to experience a piece of that not even
in in your your own country your own
like but your own home oh well I found
my uniforms Melissa Ren global news near
Brandon
Manitoba emergency evacuation ahead
thousands in Iceland flee due to fears
of a nearby volcano
[Music]
erupting a series of earthquakes in
Southwestern Iceland is sparking fears
of a nearby volcano erupting seismic
activity has cracked open roads in one
town forcing 3,000 residents to move out
of the area the Icelandic meteorological
office says there's considerable risk of
an eruption happening at any time an
aviation alert has also been raised in
response and in India more than 30
workers are trapped after a tunnel they
were working in collapsed in a landslide
rescue work is underway but it's
expected to take some time oxygen is
being pumped in through a pipe to help
the workers breathe they have sent
signals that they are
safe across India lights and oil lamps
lit up the sky as Millions celebrate the
the Hindu festival symbolizing the
victory of light over Darkness began
today festive Gatherings and prayers
will be held for a period of 5 days
across India and around the
world next a new research that shows it
was dust that did the dinosaurs in 66
million years
ago and Canada stands alone at top the
tennis
world history for Canadian tennis as
Canada's women are Billy Jean King Cup
champions for the first time ever Canada
has now won both of tennis's most
prestigious team tournaments in
back-to-back years after the men won the
Davis Cup for the first time last year
there is new research out of Belgium
that's changing our understanding of
what caused dinosaurs to go extinct
Heidi Patric
reports dust we think of it as an
annoyance an allergen something to be
cleaned up but new research suggests for
dinosaurs dust meant the difference
between life and death it's indeed a
teak layer of Sil debris um engulfing
the whole planet scientists from Bel
went to Tannis a fossil site in North
Dakota that serves as a record of the
geological effects of the massive
chickaloo asteroid which hit Earth 66
million years ago triggering the
dinosaurs mass extinction they found a
layer of ultra fine silicate dust there
and decided to explore its role in that
end the first idea was to combine the
these unique information coming from the
field with our uh newly developed um
comp computer simulations we've taken
their animation of that simulation and
enhanced it to illustrate according to
their work when the asteroid slammed
into the planet it threw up such a plume
of this dust that it enveloped the
entire Earth in just over a week
blocking out the Sun halting the
photosynthesis essential for Life think
of it like this dust storm in China a
few years back but for two whole years
this time scale uh is indeed quite long
to P severe challenges for life in the
aftermath of chicks go being packed and
that basically causes the collapse of
food chains both on land and in the
water it means whatever the asteroid
didn't kill in its fiery impact died
later of the long-term effects it was
the dust they say lingering another 15
years that played the biggest role in
dropping Earth's temperature by as much
as 15° C and animals are not good at
dealing with that so um you just end up
with these multiple cascading reasons
for a mass extinction an extreme example
she says of what rapid climate change
can do a reason why scientists monitor
asteroids in our present day solar
system for prevention after the big one
left dinosaurs in the dust Heidi pachic
Global News
Halifax and that's global national for
this Sunday night I'm far ner tonight's
your Canada is laes River in Wakefield
Quebec Donna will be back with you
tomorrow until next time take care of
yourselves and take care of each other
good
[Music]
night